Чи може Україна вже незабаром стати членом НАТО?
Колишній генсек Альянсу Андерс Фог Расмуссен запропонував ідею,
яка рідко звучить публічно.
Пропозицію опублікувало видання The Guardian.
На думку Расмуссена, Україна має стати членом НАТО, але без Криму, Донбасу
та інших окупованих Росією територій.
Цілковита надійність гарантій за п'ятою статтею (Північноатлантичного договору)
стримуватиме Росію від атак на українську територію у складі НАТО
і дозволить направити додаткові українські підрозділи на фронт.
Расмуссен вважає, що якщо Україна ввійде в НАТО без окупованих територій,
ризик прямого конфлікту між Росією і Альянсом знизиться.
Фабріс Потьє, політичний аналітик і виконавчий директор політконсалтингової фірми,
заснованої Андерсом Фог Расмуссеном, роз'яснює пропозицію ексгенсека НАТО.
За словами Потьє, ідеться про те, аби вся Україна стала членом НАТО,
а 5-та стаття про колективну оборону застосовувалася б лише до неокупованих територій.
Аналітик певен, що це буде потужним політичним сигналом.
Поставки зброї - це те, що ми маємо надавати Україні щодня.
Але цього недостатньо для повноцінного успіху України.
Політичні зобов'язання перед Україною - надважливі.
У цьому є дві сторони: членство в ЄС - сподіваюся тут буде "зелене світло в грудні
і очільники держав-членів ЄС запросять Україну, а також членство в НАТО.
На мою думку, членство в НАТО стане поворотним пунктом.
Андерс Фог Расмуссен вже тривалий час співпрацює з керівником Офісу президента Андрієм Єрмаком.
Зокрема в питанні нової архітектури європейської безпеки.
Але в Офісі президента ідею "часткового" вступу в НАТО відкидають.
Нардеп Андрій Осадчук теж вважає "план Расмуссена" неприйнятним.
Володимир Путін досі мріє про знищення України як незалежної держави.
Будь-яке заморожування конфлікту чи компроміс зі злом лише дадуть Росії час накопичити сили.
Олексій Мельник, експерт із зовнішньої політики та міжнародної безпеки,
підтверджує: ідея поступок не сприймається не лише політиками,
а і в українському суспільстві.
Колишні високопосадовці, коли вже мають велику свободу висловлювань,
пропонують такі радикальні ідеї. Це не применшує їхні колишні заслуги
чи сьогоднішній інтелектуальний потенціал, але до цього ми маємо ставитися так,
як до роздумів про те, а що можна було б зробити.
"План Расмуссена" неоднозначно сприйняли і в Брюсселі.
Деякі представники держав-членів ЄС наголосили: ціна "часткового" членства України в НАТО
буде для Києва надто високою.
Я не знаю, як нам діяти далі. Адже поняття "віддати територію" справді йде
врозріз з міжнародним правом. Я маю на увазі, що територіальна цілісність
- це те, що має бути недоторканним. Віддавати щось за щось - такого не повинно бути.
Востаннє пропозиція, схожа на "план Расмуссена", звучала у серпні.
Тоді керівник апарату генсекретаря НАТО Стіан Єнссен заявив, що відмова України
від деяких окупованих Росією територій може бути "шляхом до миру".
Ця заява викликала шквал обурення. Генсеку НАТО Єнсу Столтенбергу довелося
запевнювати, що НАТО й надалі підтримуватиме територіальну цілісність України.
Утім, підтримка Заходом українського війська не на словах, а на ділі піддається критиці.
Серед причин, чому український наступ іде повільно і складно,
фахівці називають надто повільне постачання західної зброї.
У ЄС, зокрема, визнали, що не зможуть вчасно надати Україні обіцяний
мільйон артилерійських снарядів.
Існує прірва між офіційними заявами про найкращий сценарій, у якому Україна
повертає всі свої території, і рівнем військової допомоги, яку готові надати союзники.
Їм варто задіяти весь набір інструментів, за допомогою яких можна було б змінити ситуацію
на полі бою, а потім уже можна міркувати про дипломатичні шляхи.
На думку аналітика, якщо НАТО все ж включить до свого складу неповну територію України,
це послабить і Київ, і Альянс.
Наше зобов'язання - відновити територіальну цілісність України.
Зі стратегічної, військової та юридичної точок зору, а також з огляду на репутацію Альянсу,
необхідно йти до кінця в цьому питанні.
Чи вдасться "дійти до кінця" - Олексій Мельник із Центру Разумкова радить розглядати
різні варіанти того, як надходитиме допомога Заходу і розвиватимуться події на передовій.
Є ще так звані "чорні лебеді". 7 жовтня - це був один із "чорних лебедів".
Що ще на нас чекає? Не дай Бог, якийсь потужний землетрус з величезною кількістю жертв,
виверження вулкану, чергова пандемія і так далі - те, що не передбачується.
Є речі, які можуть чинити такий вплив на цей конфлікт, що дійсно не залишиться вибору,
як іти на якісь надзвичайно болючі компроміси.
На останньому саміті НАТО у Вільнюсі влітку цьогоріч замість запрошення до Альянсу
Україна отримала запевнення союзників у членстві після перемоги.
Наступний 75-й саміт Північноатлантичного альянсу відбудеться у Вашингтоні влітку 2024 року.
Членство України в НАТО знову буде однією з провідних тем.
Та чи буде воно запропоноване Україні і в якому форматі -
багато в чому залежатиме від ситуації на фронті.